I think the Snowden case has elevated
everyone's awareness of the sort of
panopticon that we now live in I've been
writing about this for years that about
a sort of a future where you have
pervasive surveillance but the Snowden
documents have revealed to us that it's
far worse than we ever imagined and we
have to push back against this black
phone is a smartphone that has been
created for the express purpose of
protecting users privacy it protects
your online activities from observation
by others the content of your of your
phone calls is encrypted so that no one
can wiretap you no one else can listen
to the phone call except the two people
that are on the phone call criminals
have access to the same technology as
the rest of us you know the nine eleven
hijackers purchase GPS receivers to
guide their airplanes to their targets
GPS is a technology developed by the
Pentagon to guide weapons to their
targets so what are we supposed to do
stop selling GPS receivers we think the
cryptographic protocols that we're using
that we design it silent circle we've
designed them in such a way that we hope
that we think we have reason to think
that major governments can't break them
by pure crypt analysis but there are so
many other ways to break into pounds we
can push back against this with
technology tools like black phone and
like silent circle products
but we're going to need to do more than
that we need to push back in policy
space we have to change the laws